good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday very
slow crawl to the end of the week but
we're getting there slowly but
definitely surely yeah eventually we
will you know cuz that's the funny thing
about like time it just keeps moving so
do you ever think like when you're in a
moment that's painful you're like
inevitably eventually this moment will
be over this day will be over I always
think about it when I'm having like a
really bad stomachache I'm like in an
hour like you're gonna be in your bed
and you're gonna be like feeling bad for
yourself in this moment oh yeah that's
how I feel when I'm hungover I'm like
soon oh yeah back on this day and just
feel sorry for myself totally I
definitely do that as well time that is
the thing about time it must keep going
yeah it just keeps moving like we could
sit here and not say anything but then
eventually the show would end in an hour
you know no and like the day would still
go on and the day would still be dreary
as hell very rainy it's been raining for
about a week in New York which I never
have felt so personally like invested in
the weather partially because our show
looks so beautiful when it's sunny out
and when it's raining out it just looks
ugly and Theo like being walked in the
rain is just it's such a task it takes
him longer to pee because he's like
confused as to why there's like water on
the floor and then it comes back all
like wet and I have to give him a bath
it's so torturous that is torturous and
now our show really is dependent on the
weather but it dawned on me the other
day that like we're very close to spring
I'm really excited for for spring to
sprung spring is a good one
you know I don't really hate the winter
I find like stylistically I thrive in
terms of clothing in the winter I just
feel more comfortable in like a baggy
baggy sweater and a tight leather
legging so um I do I do just like what I
have to wear in spring but I do like the
feeling of like I'm watching Sex in the
City and they put it so perfectly like
on the episode where Miranda proposes to
Steve they're sitting outside drinking
beers and Carrie when she's narrating in
her really annoying voice she says every
New Yorker on every like nice autumn day
acts like it's the last one they're ever
gonna get like what it's nice in New
York like literally they're going to the
park we're sitting outside especially in
autumn because it might be the last one
we're ever gonna get autumn is just so
such a beautiful time I've been watching
Sex in the City which I know we have
recaps on the show multiple times but I
just feel like every time i rewatch it I
have like a fresh perspective on
everything and it's crazy how really
people can change because like
ten years ago like when I was in my
group of friends they were like I'm the
sous Manta you're the carry like nobody
wanted to be the Miranda I have now
rewatching coming to terms fully with
the fact that I definitely I'm the
Miranda she's literally the best
character she's so funny she's probably
shouts the richest but she's right up
there second partner in a law firm she
works hard for her money like she's an
independent woman she knows what she
wants she like ended up with like a nice
family like I just and she's so funny
and cynical I found myself like anytime
I like belly laugh at the show it's
always at what Miranda saying so I just
saw I want to apologize for all the mean
things I said about Miranda over the
years and I honestly wish you know that
she was our governor okay like I don't
want to rain on your parade and they
don't want to embarrass you but I would
be remiss devastated in Harper and if I
didn't tell you that like we're honestly
both carries oh yeah
Jackie if Carrie were here in 2020 like
she would be an influence because it's a
job podcast no but it's just like the
spirit like no no I literally I have
nothing in common with Carrie
I guess personality-wise like you're the
sweeper the super Mary Miranda you know
literally carry my cycle in fact that
she hug by in the supermarket sweeper
because we have a new studio and I'll
clean up here's what she does every day
in her life like she just decides she's
in cleanup mode and just sweeps the
place you'll never find anything you're
welcome we don't need a cleaning lady
because I'm here so what I'm saying
cause that is very Miranda be like in
the home you are in Miranda no Chucky
you're starting the worst again you're a
Carrie in the streets no I'm not Randa
in the she wouldn't be saying we were
anything like Carrie if she didn't own a
laptop like literally the fact that she
thinks no I'm absolutely nothing like
Harry I disagree with all of her
decision-making all of her mannerisms I
hate everything she wears she lives for
a kitten here like my shoes my shoes
like you know it sounds like I'm nothing
like her like I'm really a Miranda okay
okay fine honest I'm a little bit smoky
so you're like it Carrie more thing into
Miranda because it's like no I'm not a
Carrie yes you are you're my happiness
no I'm not you are no I'm not a
protecting this who makes bad decisions
in calorie as well JD I'm not a
self-loathing Carrie because I'm not a
Carrie I'm not like I just I can't
believe that you would even say that
about me I'm sorry I'm saying about
myself too and you know how I feel you
know what you are again right now yes
you are I am NOT anyone no you I
the show no you are a carry I think and
I used to be a carry and now a morphing
into a Charlotte oh by the way you are
definitely a 50/50 split of Charlotte
and Carrie and I feel like I'm 75
percent Miranda 25 percent to Smith I
actually think oh do you say Samantha
yeah oh I totally agree that you are a
percentage of Samantha a hundred percent
and I feel it's so proud of that hear
more Samantha than Miranda or Carrie
know what I really relate to Miranda is
like it's her level of realism like she
just has no time for [ __ ] she's so
realistic like she knows when she's
being played like she just she lives on
planet earth and Carrie literally lives
on another dimension where she could pay
her bills you know with shoes yeah and
she has to say shoes like shoes you know
ya know I dunno so don't say I'm sorry I
didn't know is such a turner for you I
was just contributing to the coat so
invested in the show now like I'm on
season six like she's dating Alexander
Petrovsky place to be it's such a
there's there's certain phases of the
show that I find intolerable the
Alexander Petrovsky phase being one of
them he's just so ugly first of all I'm
like we're supposed to act like well she
got this guy studio 54 he's like 75
years old like studio 54 I mean come on
the dream is dead you get over it if
your claim to fame is steel studio 54
like she'd she won't for you bro yeah so
I just I'm having a hard time watching
that but it's also that the Harry and
Charlotte phase which is the best phase
well I've been spending my time watching
curb and it's just everything so
everything of the story everything of
the sort like oh my god
you know who cracks me up the most Oh
Susie Jeff's wife of course she's better
she's literally in those character you
piece of [ __ ] she's so funny I love I
love the show me too I like Jeff Garlin
- I love him yeah he's a cutie anyways
so I guess we're just watching all the
HBO content can't wait for HBO man no
honestly like the way you started
redheads book club like I think I need
to start like let's watch old TV shows I
actually had a treatment for a podcast
like two years ago that I sold to like a
network I never did but I thought it'd
be a good idea like a TV book club or
like go back I never watched like Will
and Grace you know I don't you do that I
know I should you really shed I actually
can commit to watching a season a month
you know yeah a week you know like I
actually can do that so if anyone
wouldn't find that interesting I need to
stop like saying I'm gonna do stuff
because you know I'm never gonna do it
like maybe I would I don't know like
sometimes when the passions just
overwhelm you can't help but to do it
and that's how I feel about the right
heads book club and you know that's how
I feel about
exactly I've just spent like all my time
making content for the Instagram I
actually listen to the podcast even
though you know I don't know how to read
and I didn't read the book but I thought
it was hysterical Rebecca is perfect
you're the way you describe everyone it
really for people I thought was too many
to be on a podcast but everyone really
plays up specific we're like Dana is the
encyclopedia she's the professor
honestly Rebecca's the star she's so
funny like I was DMing her cuz I put on
my story that I was listening she's like
was it good I'm like Becky you're a star
she was meant to podcast she's so funny
and she's actually so funny in person
and any time we'd like introduced her to
someone people are always she's the type
of person that like people are really
taken by ya like she makes an amazing
first and last impression right like my
friend she's like I said on the podcast
she's very socially apt like different
social situations that present
themselves in the book and I was there
Rebecca is our resident like normal
person who knows what to do what would
you have done in that situation my
friend Abe met her and like the next day
like not even in a romantic way he was
like wow I was just right I'm like I
know yeah everyone feels that way he's
coming through on the podcast she's a
great gal everyone really has a
different um role different role in like
different set of favorites of books even
Snitch and I were similar in so many
ways we're so different when it comes to
books yeah so I do feel like we're like
this Sex in the City of book clubs like
are you it so who okay who's the cat oh
god I cannot discover so yeah okay I
carry in the book club
oh I narrate so inevitably I'm the carry
I'm the protagonist yeah I would say
that Rebecca is the Samantha okay I
would say Dana is the Miranda and then
snitches the Charlotte good for her I'm
happy for her she's right on the podcast
actually because we were aware that
there's four of us so we didn't want to
talk over each other and I think we did
a really good job but I think the other
girls like needed more introduction yeah
and you can't have a book like it can't
be a book club if there's only two or
three people like it really needs to be
not a club a club yeah so I mean we have
thousands of people when it comes to
their head head so anyways listen if
you've read the book or if you haven't
because it's just friends hanging out
and it's a good time that's me the clubs
are all about anyway like pretending
you're gonna read and then just hang out
with your friends yeah even though I
intend on doing the reading and a lot of
people are reading a lot of people are
reading it you're up to see it you're
helping America's like group average in
terms of like English class if that is
the legacy I leave on this earth
I'm shocked that's me considering I
never did the reading in school not once
um but I'm happy to do it also I've been
looking for the next book I'm gonna read
personally and actually the book that
Rebecca suggested for the next book club
is something that I was going to read
anyway so I'm so excited
um back to just like required reading in
college I actually like I'm incredibly
proud of the fact and I and I'm not even
exaggerating one tiny bit like I made it
through four years of college and
graduated without ever once doing any
sort of required reading I don't even
think half the time I had the textbook
yeah and I just feel proud of that you
know I think it's a good thing to know
like students should maybe know that you
don't have to do all the readings you
don't have to be like a sneaky Brown was
there with your hand up all the time
especially do not put your hand up if
you did not do the reading I can't
believe the people with the balls like
that it's like how do you even know what
you're talking about because it's its
strategic as one of those people like
you your worst nightmare is getting
called on when you don't raise your hand
because she knows you didn't do the
reading so if you raise your hand for
something like obvious in the beginning
or even if you get it wrong it's worth
getting it wrong in the beginning of the
class so that when like people are
getting tired and no one's listening
she's not gonna cold call on you very
strategic I did it many times I actually
did towards the end of college start to
do the readings and I still wouldn't put
my hand up I did the reading just in
case I got called on like without my
hand up I just think the proudest moment
to this day which I still think is
technically a technical error I had a
very hard communications class and I'd
into any of the reading and
communications classes are all based
around the readings and on the final I
got a 99 out of 100 which I didn't even
think was possible and I'm still pretty
sure it was like a glitch in the NYU
computer system but your girl got an A I
think it's also worth noting like you
can be a communications major if you're
not doing the readings but maybe you
know our doctors and scientists coming
up should be real it's not pre-med you
know finance just do the reading like we
need you people like you need to exist
so I can access because we balance each
other out hundred-percent there's room
for everyone there's truly room for
everyone you guys okay well we have a
great show for you today actually have
some stories I feel passionately about
are we gonna recap The Bachelor gonna
recap if I had so many a thought I have
so many thought alright so I think and
actually was speaking this morning to uh
Kelly and I just want to say I watched
you bash last night and I woke up in the
middle of the night with a migraine so
there's a correlation one plus one
equals suck there's actually one plus
one equals migraine here whatever yeah
it makes
I don't know if I'm whoever unless
Kelly's a bachelorette next season I'm
saying it now I'm not watching because
honestly it's bad for my physical and
mental health I spoke to her this
morning she damn me that kind of drama I
felt really excited about it
she responded to my Instagram story
about a cease take on The Bachelor which
everyone's been waiting for by the way
he kept four campers and sent home two
counselors that's exactly what happens
exactly what we'll talk about it at the
end of the episode okay so without
further ado it is time for the past five
stories that you yes you in the back
seat of the taxi need to know but you
study up and take a bite out of your
morning toast that's had notes makes me
hungry um this show always makes me
hungry just you know what makes me
hungry being alive like I've been so
[ __ ] hungry again period yes oh my
god think sister and every time I get it
I'm like oh that's why I've been so
hungry but it's like I was hungry the
whole months yeah hey great um
till it's time and we have so much to
discuss and I really don't want to like
step on anyone's toes because this is
you know 50% your show because I'm
wearing new shoes and they're suede if
you step on my toes like it'll be a
problem Carrie Carrie
you know what Carrie would actually love
though cuz she was always like remember
that episode where they're smelling
fragrances and she's like I've taken a
lot of Stanford she would love Stanford
because she couldn't find her fragrance
when she was shopping no she couldn't
have you ever gone up to someone and
asked you smell amazing what perfume
you're wearing scent is the most
powerful sense you have a smell can
bring out a flood of memories influence
your mood and of course enhance her
natural style but while you're looking
for that signature scent that will make
you stand out and keep the memory of you
lingering on your taste can be expensive
and buying a full bottle of perfume
anytime you want to try something new
can be a hit or miss with scent bird you
can have a great taste and mix up your
fragrance routine without breaking the
bank
whether it's Tom Ford Gucci a Versace
semper comm keeps you smelling good
month after month scent bird is a luxury
fragrance subscription service perfect
for perfumes and colognes with more than
600 designer brands for you to choose
from each month you choose the perfume
you want to try they'll send you a 30
day supply if we're not sure what type
of scent you're looking for you can sort
and find your new fragrance by brands
style occasions season and more plus
they now carry products from other
categories like skincare wellness and
makeup scent bird carries brands like
Aparri glam glow glow recipe tart and so
many others so it's really everything
you need to get out the door and with
our exclusive offer just for our
listeners you can get 30% off your first
month of scent bird today that's only
ten dollars
your first fragrance now that offer
recently changed so make sure you're
listening because I know a lot of people
use it go to scent bird comm slash Steen
and use the promo code Steen for 30% off
your first month again that's scen
t-bird dot-com slash Steen to sign up
and use our promo code Steen ste n to
try your first perfume or cologne for
just ten dollars sign on smell amazing
it loves tempered it's just it's always
gonna be that show and sent participant
you know Jackie I totally agree I feel
like you know the the lead sponsor
always sets like a tone for the show
yeah and scent bird is just everything
of the sort everything okay
first story I always find this
interesting let me know if you guys are
over these stories though
Oscar viewership hits an all-time low
with twenty three point six million
viewers I saw it was a historic 90
second Academy Awards with a first Best
Picture recipient not in the English
language in parasite adding an element
of surprise to a largely predictable
winners list there was something else
too stark in the ratings for the 2020
Oscars to a historic low so usually the
Oscars are around 40 million viewers
which is like 100 many and this year was
twenty three point six million still a
ton right as much as you see to me this
doesn't seem like a failure just because
every year every award show we report on
this being like viewership is down and
it really doesn't have a lot to do with
the Oscars more so people just not
having cable like you don't even have
cable no but I watch the Oscars you know
what I mean like it's just it's TV
trends it's not the Oscar trend like
people are watching TV on cable less and
less oh you think it's that yeah I think
it's that people are tired of like
nonsense that award shows no I don't and
I think that like even the Golden Globes
was like better this year than it's been
past
I'm just keep referencing the Golden
Globes cuz I think that like there's a
finally a good award sure it's a good
award show they chose a host like with a
point of view and it was it was good
yeah but I think with the Oscars like
people are just are they're tired of it
like yeah I think that um maybe it's a
little bit of both
because people in general are watching
TV less I think like every year there's
a major like moment on TV the next day
we're always reporting how ratings are
down it makes it sound like a bad thing
but it's just people are different now
if people are gathering around their TV
set with their antennas watching the
Oscars like things are different in
trendy way but what about this Super
Bowl what didn't know worship
not report on it I think so I feel like
it was it felt like it was one of the
highest-rated Super Bowl it should have
been it was sensational from the game to
the half I thought it was such I was
actually thinking about the game this
morning I forget what what thought
process I was going on I think a lot
while I do my makeup because what else
is there to do literally nothing and I
was thinking about how the game this
year was a good game of like they were
losing then they were win it not fun
when someone says she's just winning the
whole time yeah
I got a bunch of dm's actually about
people who listen to the show saying
that we but like mostly may have been
saying by the way too much I think it's
my way of interrupting you like you're
saying something oh by the way I mean by
the way I don't know I don't think it's
a bad honestly watching The Bachelor
last night the girls they say like so
much Madison thought I would be anyone
like to be the popcorn to judge totally
infuriating and if anything I know that
we've been saying it less and less but
we still say it a lot people who've
never listened to our show come up to
listen to our show and they're like what
are they saying also adding you actually
started saying I feel as though and it
definitely helped me stay like a little
bit less I still say more than the
average person now I feel more committed
than ever to continue on this journey of
saying like less Madison when she was
talking about her faith I don't know if
she was just nervous because it's like
something that's obviously really really
close to her heart but she actually was
going like this mmm my faith like you
know it's just like you know like
important to me and like I just want to
like make sure that like you're like I'm
a like same age but so much slower and
yeah I've given her a pass because it
was a tough subject for her to broach
but this has been consistent all season
I only noticed it last night oh oh my
okay I'm glad you noticed it too and you
know when you watch TV with subtitles
which I've actually really been doing
recently for certain shows it's so much
more apparent because it's right in
front of your face yeah and as I'm
talking about the subject I'm trying so
hard not to say like even once of course
and anyone who criticizes our show for
saying like too much I just need like
some sort of concrete proof that you
don't watch The Bachelor because if
you're able to watch The Bachelor you
should be able to watch this with yeah I
think I became a hyper aware of my likes
when I started doing more stand up
because it's intolerable in person yeah
and you actually trying to do that one
yeah
- I was like I said haha I said the show
is amazing so amazing if I had to give
one critique is you like becomes a
crutch of course because you're like
waiting for and you don't have to
articulate yourself in such a decisive
way when you say like it takes the sting
away of something that you may be saying
and sometimes it's kind of funny so when
you're trying to be funny you're like
like oh yeah you know it's funny yeah
and I was like bye yeah you know mm-hmm
also I realized that I say you know
literally so much I I don't care if I'm
saying anything too much unless it's
like well yeah yeah even if it's a
thousand percent what else do we say we
say a lot of [ __ ] anyways so even um
I'll take yeah like is bad like because
of the connotation like people give it
like a stigma mm-hmm you gotta take back
the stigma I'm taking back taking back
our likes like a look-alike like a
look-alike okay next up Macaulay Culkin
is defending Michael Jackson in an
Esquire cover story what Macaulay Culkin
opens up about his close friendship with
Michael Jackson his closest , weird
friendship with Michael Jackson but we
all know that they were friends and that
was a you know some of the subtext in
the documentary yeah like Macaulay
Culkin was definitely one of the kids
but he's like so traumatized that he's
not gonna say anything he's always said
that nothing ever happened yeah and he
is saying in Esquire quote he never did
anything to me I never saw him do
anything and especially at this flash
point in time I'd have no reason to hold
anything back that's true the guy has
passed on if anything I'm not gonna say
it would be stylish or anything like
that but right now is a good time to
speak up and if I had something to speak
up about I would totally do it
but no I never saw anything Wow I mean
that's so crazy Barry cut and try like
he's not cutting he's not being big like
I just don't believe it like I believe
him but then it goes back to what Dave
Chappelle said you know what he said if
you're like abusing children and like
you're gonna go for a man who's the best
one yeah he was the cutest yeah I mean
it's just it's so Michael Jackson thing
like really I think is like difficult
for a lot of people to process because I
feel like up until people were talking
about Michael Jackson or up until the
documentary came out like we were just
unabashedly believing victims and now
we're like maybe we're not you know and
so many people are having a hard time
believing this because he was such an
icon I found myself to be very convinced
by the documentary but so many people
like from both like celebrities to just
normal average people are really torn
about it like whether or not it happened
or not and I just feel like when you
know how anyone could think it didn't
happen is strange because he was running
around town with like a bunch of kids
it's like a 13 year old like that's
[ __ ] weird
yeah and inappropriate regardless of
whether he was putting this but they
send the documentary his tongue in their
buttholes yeah I agree I think I think
Macaulay Hill didn't story can be true
and the documentary can be true yeah I
guess but I don't know it's just I feel
like when you're at that like you're not
selective with who you choose to abuse
and who choose to not reviews and he was
hanging out with Macaulay Culkin so much
like I don't know it's just weird yeah
and the documentary who really convinced
me that like Macaulay Culkin was like
the key to this entire thing me too and
if Macaulay Culkin ever is going to
speak out about if it did happen to him
he I think would be like the nail in the
coffin whereas everyone would finally
like believe and cancel and stop playing
his music like are Kelly I think that he
would be the only thing that could turn
the world okay but like what if he
didn't abuse him right I don't know I
just don't see how it doesn't to me I
just don't see how you can abuse a bunch
of kids and then not Macaulay Culkin
when you're hanging out you know what I
mean like yeah if you're abusing those
other kids weren't gonna be abused
Macaulay Culkin
I know McCulloch lookin was probably the
most famous of them he's already in
homel it's true we're leaning on Michael
Ferdinand Tillery you know that's very
true actually so who knows that'll thing
that Jackie memory was creepy as [ __ ]
is such that was a dark time with like
all these documentaries coming out
surviving our Kelly oh I just think that
we're we're the documentary gets a
little iffy for me is that after that it
came out there were a couple
discrepancies that they have like gotten
wrong would check if you're gonna come
at someone you're like full force you
need to have all your facts right and
there was a lot of stuff with like the
never Neverland blueprints how like this
wasn't actually there and they were like
a little like choppy on some of the
details which is a little you if you're
coming and making crazy accusations you
can't be wrong yes but you're also
child I I don't they were recounting
these right I'm not saying the victims
the documentary interion
yeah like just like statistical facts
the details about like how
never-never-land was laid out cuz they
got the blueprints from City Hall like
just random things that were not
factually correct no of course the
victims not gonna remember everything
about a 10 remembered so much holy and I
mean of course it's traumatizing so you
remember certain things but if it's
happening so frequently over the course
of 10 15 years
you don't remember every rendezvous yeah
and the exact location right enough like
where the train track was yeah that's
the other thing okay so like you want to
say Michael Jackson didn't abused kids
fine but like why does he turn his house
into a playground for kids to come to
like it's just weird like what 30 year
old man is like his number one priority
it's like to make random children happy
like it's not Santa Claus well the
argument is he was stunted because he
got famous so young yes and he was
abused as well so yes hurt people hurt
people but it's not an excuse okay
that's also something I find um
difficult to like cope with when you
watch these documentaries like Aaron
Hernandez or there are Kelly documentary
like are Kelly was a molested by a
family member when he was a kid and like
you're feeling so torn emotionally
because you're supposed to feel bad for
them but also like they're the devil you
know yeah so that's also like a like a
vicious cycle where when you're watching
a documentary you're not entirely sure
how to feel but of course the
documentarians have to tell you that
because it is a part of why I'm a part
of the story and I think any good
documentary is gonna leave you feeling a
lot of different ways now yeah it
shouldn't just be clear-cut this is how
you should feel because right then
they're influencing and they just need
supposed to tell us gives axed
totally ok next story um Cindy
Crawford's on Presley Gerber has
received a face tattoo that says Asajj
tattoo that says misunderstood
um he's also defending his tattoo saying
quote you don't know how I feel of
course because you're misunderstood
right the 20 year old model who is the
son of Cindy Crawford and businessman
Randy Gerber defended his recent
decision to get behind a container to
have a businessman beau this is a
definition she was one of the first yes
she was a pioneer I'm sorry for
interrupting
defended his recent decision to get a
fox tattoo responding to the backlash
over his new body art in an Instagram
live video on Saturday quote you don't
know how I feel
you're not in my head he said I don't
feel very understood I guess that that
does you know tend to happen when you
are misunderstood so I don't really
follow the life and career of Pressley
Gerber but when I saw this tattoo like I
it's so crazy
no it's nuts it's literally in the
middle of his cheek even if he wants to
get it removed like his face will
forever be [ __ ] up because of it and
he's really giving me Chet Hanks vibes
are you following all this Chet Hanks
stuff who okay I'm not a hundred percent
sure of his name is Chet but you know
Tom Hanks and Rita Wilson have been
making the award show
so rounds because he's nominated for mr.
Robinson mr. Rogers erat a beautiful day
in the neighborhood
yes so they've been bringing their kids
and you know he has that one kid see
that movie you know he's a lot of hype
about the trailer but nothing after that
didn't even come out yeah but he got
nominated so it must have been good so
he's been making the award show circuit
with his kids and you know he has the
kid Colin Hanks you know like everyone
loves and he was in House Bunny yes oh
my god laughs him and then he has like
some cute daughter and her name weirdly
as Elizabeth Hanks so it's like
Elizabeth Banks you know and then they
have another kid Chet I think that's his
name and he's like the bad seed and he
was like on these red carpets at the
Golden Globes like making these cringy
ask Instagram videos he like does all
these accents that are like borderline
racist and it's just he's definitely the
problem child he's like spiky hair in a
tattoo like he's just he's nuts and face
tattoo I thought you tattoo or it's like
a neck tattoo and they they did leave
him home from the Oscars I think they
decided that he no longer needed to be a
stain on the family name
so he's reminded me of Preston so so far
I don't like I said follow Missy Gerber
so I don't know like what else he's been
up to but like a face tattoo is just so
dark so still permanent and it's weird
because like post Malone has face
tattoos and like I think they're so cute
okay well Brent what's the same Presley
Gerber is like not a rapper yeah and
he's like there's a lot so now right any
if he's gonna be the face of a campaign
like it has to be a misunderstood brand
right and there aren't many there are a
few I feel like that could be really
funny there's just certain industries
where you can have a face tattoo and
where you can't modeling is one of the
industries where you can't and rapping
is one of the industries where you can
yeah and I feel like
you're gonna get a face like if you're
hell-bent on getting a face tattoo like
there are things that you could maybe
get that aren't misunderstood yeah like
maybe a tattooed mustache or you can get
one in your lip or a micro bladed
eyebrow oh yeah they also have the white
tattoos I love the in your life yeah and
those are only semi-permanent like they
do wash away in a few years you also get
white tattoos that wear like your skin
like kind of puffs up like there's just
there are options for you Presley but I
hope he's doing well you know it's
almost like this had to happen because
the Gerber Crawford family is just like
a little too perfect you know like the
mom is perfect the dad is perfect kaya's
perfect so like and you saw what's his
name I'm having such a Preston Presley
Presley you know he was like this like
you know I've been coming along like
something had to happen cuz it's just
not fair so yeah and he can't get it
removed online but you don't get a
tattoo to get it removed no no once you
especially on your Fox like once you're
getting that far in the chair the
needles you know needling you're lying
there in the pain because you're gonna
get it removed and I mad I know tattoos
are painful and in certain places
they're more painful and than others and
I have to assume the cheek is a highly
painful locale for a tattoo over first
sure and it looks like he has like high
cheekbones so it was like hitting phone
sister wait I've got the gog cheek yeah
be really more painful no I feel oh yeah
because [ __ ] and pushing the pain you
know kids these days so misunderstood so
misunderstood okay um the thing what's
not misunderstood my love for cope re no
that is crystal clear and my love for
CBD with everything everything that's
going on in the news our number one New
Year's resolution has been just to chill
out which is much easier said than done
but sometimes it's as simple as taking a
few moments for yourself to soothe your
body in mind one of our favorite ways to
do that is with the new CBD products
from cope re you've definitely heard
about from us they're organic vegan
premium grade coconut oil products and
that's the same attention to ingredients
that makes their CBD line the one to
trust
papyrus products use the only
full-spectrum CBD whole plant powder on
the market combined with their famous
coconut oil and maximum absorption and
ultimate nourishment Kapaa res is
dedicated to sustainable and quality
sourcing theirs as their CBD plants as
they are with their coconuts if you've
got any aches kinks in your muscles or
anything that needs to relief their CBD
body balm cream and recovery balm
go on smooth and feel amazing
sorry CBD deodorant can help soothe
inflammation and has the freshest
herbaceous lavender scent and love an
herbaceous lavender Sam um its CBD not
THC so they're coconut CBD products
won't get you high
they'll just soothe even calm you with
some of nature's biggest power players
pair to perfection if you're gonna try
CBD or you've been wanting to try CBD do
it the right way you can trust and go
with cope re so if you've been wanting
to see what all the CBD hype is about
let's B let this be the nudge that you
need you can get 15% off all CBD
products right now when you go to cope
re beauty calm / toast
that's a cope re beauty calm / toast for
15 percent off your order cope re beauty
calm / toast cope are you spelled Kop AR
I sign on and relax yeah love cope re
amazing brand people are sharing um
tattoos that they've gotten that are
funny please share and someone got bad
[ __ ] only on there but when they were
drunk that's fair if you got a tattoo
what would you get now I'm thinking I
got in my lips
no so I I would get I think we've had
this conversation before
yes so I would get the word mich Baca in
Hebrew in family but I don't uh
which means family in Hebrew I don't
know where I would get it though like I
think a lip no I think like between my
titties you know cuz like no one's ever
gonna see it familial what about you um
I think now I'm saying now I'm going lip
because it fades and I would get rocks
tini vibes which means seen vibes only
in Hebrew love it I would love that
you know people have been getting spoon
tattoos like any other horse like that
is so flattering so flattering
rocks teeny vibes I'll even handwrite it
for you someone came to my show like
straight from the tattoo parlor and they
got a spoon on their ass and it was just
to me that is like the highest form of
flattery like you really you like love a
nice form so much in 5-10 years like
you'll be happy with that hopefully yeah
but maybe like if even 5-10 years like
she's over the toes inception could be
like oh I just love soup yeah or like
you know food yeah the spoon is actually
a replica of like a spoon what my
grandma gave me or something like you
can make something up
exactly okay or you can go on that MTV
show with Snooki and Nico Tortorella
where they like cover up tattoos and
[ __ ] yes yeah that's a good show fake
resume apparently belonging to lore
Laurens daughter has been released in
the College Admission scandal okay so
Olivia Jade's fake rowing resume he has
been released with some piece of
evidence so therefore it's public it's
public record some of it has been
redacted but it's enough to know that it
was her because it's G annually
graduated 2018 I wonder why they
redacted the other stuff probably
there's an address like that and you're
not getting pulled over there's just a
siren behind us please feel free to
ignore and they might have redacted
anything that has nothing to do with
rowing because it's not pertinent run
tuition but it is a very extensive list
of competitions that she participated in
and some of her skill sets for rowing it
is worth noting that a source close to
the G annually said that this
application was not filled out by anyone
in their family it was filled out
unbeknownst to them by someone at USC
what like someone that may be the person
at USC who you know was responsible for
facilitating these arrangements okay
there's just kind of sex I feel like
Olivia Jade's really trying to like
resurface
she's like posting a lot of Instagram
she did a couple YouTube videos and this
is just like the problem with like the
particulate that she's in is that it's
an ongoing trial like Felicity Huffman
thing is over but Lori Loughlin is gonna
be much more dragged out and so as much
as she wants like resurfaced and just
have people stopped talking about this
they did stop talking about it briefly
and she was like putting up YouTube
videos but because it's an ongoing story
there's gonna be new stories about it
every couple weeks yeah and it just like
sucks she's not allowed to comment on it
so it's not like your regular
cancellation right where you can you
know makes a pimple and and let them
know your perspective she has to be
totally quiet and we have to be okay
with that if we like as fans totally um
sucks yeah but I am glad that she's
getting back out there because because
if you don't a hard time if you don't
like you never will mm-hmm and I think
that like regardless of how you feel
about the situation or any cancellation
in general like that like time period
where you take off and then come back is
like the timing is so specific like you
know who I think is on like a little bit
of a break very quietly as Gina
Rodriguez but then I saw her somewhere
weird recently and
I don't know if it was a commercial or a
movie trailer or something or something
ice but I said he's been very quiet cuz
she went through it and she handled it
very poorly yeah it's like it's not
always about the crime it's like also
about the cover-up you know yeah like
what you do this what you did but how
are you gonna handle it and she handled
it very poorly yeah but now I'm sure
she'll be back she'll be fine but
anyways
okay next two stories are I'm grouping
them together because I want to talk
about both of them um both a little bit
of Twitter stories as in people are
tweeting and my first favorite new
Twitter series from Chrissy Teigen it's
talking about the Vanity Fair party
which I need to talk about for a second
stellar pictures came out like yesterday
after the show and it's everyone is
there the photo opportunities are
everything it's literally the like the
cream of the crop like I don't think
anyone can just get invited no but it's
the cream of the crop but it's the
entire crop yeah you know like everybody
knows everyone they're like competing
after parties like after the Grammys
there's like a bunch you know this guy
has won no no there's just one yeah and
everyone like puts on new looks the
people who didn't go to the Oscars come
out they put on better looks literally
ashy and Shoah
the Kardashians looked [ __ ]
phenomenal Vanessa and Hudgens looked
spectacular Nikki Hilton looked like
everyone just wore the best of the best
yeah oh who did I see oh the cast of
Riverdale I was there looking mature as
hell yeah love to see it who asked every
model in the world every model in the
world really just showered did a good
job of rounding up the pictures on their
Instagram it was so fun to see yeah it
makes you wonder what goes on inside
because it seems like everyone just goes
there to get that picture really quickly
before we jump into the chrissy teigen
thing did you see like it's like it's
just not a lot of people but it's a
small trend that people are celebrities
are now like putting their money where
their mouth is and re wearing old gowns
that they've worn to like over the last
10 years because like they're you know
always preaching about like
sustainability and like the environment
but like you know the fashion industry
is one of like the most wasteful
industries and they're like having
couture gowns made 5 times a year so
laura dern we were at the Vanity Fair
Oscar party a dress she wore years ago
Jane Fonda when she presented rewar a
dress so I think it's actually pretty
cool
I love this trend I am
big fan of rewiring outfits I am an
outfit repeater to the sweater literally
last week no especially when I buy a
dress for an event like and I love the
dress and they spent a lot of money on
it I'm gonna wear it to multiple events
some people like call me out or like me
Mitch well it there's a dress that we've
both worn probably two or three times
each but like it was an expensive dress
like we're getting our money before
Jackie and totally and I'm like what
like you don't need to send yourself
it's so [ __ ] up I think this is so
great it's like I'm so done with
celebrities like preaching about climate
change and they're like taking their
planes everywhere you know it's like
Natalie Portman wearing the gown with
all the female directors who were
snubbed on it meanwhile she's never
actually worked with a female director
like I live for like them
you know calling calling people out and
then like not doing anything to actually
help and to me this is they just talk
the talk but they don't walk the well or
adjourn and her old gown are walking the
walk on the Vanity Fair Oscar carpet and
I am here for it I just wanted to say
that or at the very least like if they
want to like wear a gown once please
like put it on the real real so that I
can buy Lucy Boynton's dress yeah I mean
that's like oh my god pastel dreams she
is just she is something else she is
something else she is as like a style
icon of our generation she shows up and
she hits it every single time I red
carpet but always wearing something
interesting like anyone can look great
on the red carpet all the time if you
don't take chances right but she is just
always serving us something different
and I'm obsessed with her and if anybody
taught me to try something different and
take chances it's Celine Dion of course
what do you say to Taking Chances
wedding you say to jump in
oh the edge that was beautiful like was
really good I'm gonna quit while I'm
ahead
Claudia that's beautiful Jackie has been
quoting my comedy show like in everyday
conversation because you saw it 100
times and there's like little things
that I said Jackie has been imitating me
I can't wait forever to see it I'm just
someone I think I don't know what this
says about me but I really pick up I'm
like inflection like I have inflection
memory so where it's like in when we
learned in um when you read Torah it's
like trope yeah um so the way that
someone like will say something with a
sing-song
just I always remember it and then I
implemented into everyday life you're
just such a smooth sailor I mean
implementor you're an implementer okay
back to Christa tikitiki and is tweeting
the Vanity Fair party is of course the
best and most coveted official Oscar
party but you must complete or dodge
five tasks before actually seeing the
party or or I assume you just go missing
the tasks coveted mark Salinger photo
shoot everyone wants to do this and not
everyone can i need clarification on
what allows you to do this no I'm sure
it's just like the creme like this is
the cream of the crop and then yeah they
go to that DeNiro have on right those
who get to be photographed for any
markets the cream of the cream of the
crop yeah but it's like did you shame
and she'll have one I don't think so
she said this is a fun but I Shay
Mitchell looked [ __ ] amazing amazing
like Jessica Rabbit real mess this is a
fun task then you must enter the tomb of
lasers and dance for a video which is so
funny because you always see those like
weird videos I actually only saw a Kim
and Kanye one this year I didn't see any
I just saw Kamath honey it looked so
easy I was like where did they find
brought its own lasers then you must
either stomp on the heads of the two
social media people or succumb to their
demands next it's time to use your power
up to get on FaceTime with someone's
daughter they will be a huge fan you
must be very excited or they will tweet
you finally you have met the head boss
someone you do not recognize but must
remember them this conversation will be
18 minutes long then she said it is
worth it with a cute picture of her face
timing with clearly Jessica Alba's
daughter Thank You Vanity Fair oh that's
so cute I don't know I think at some
point like Chrissy Teigen is like you
know she's pulling the curtain back
letting us all see like at some point
people are gonna stop letting her in
places because she's giving away all the
secrets no but Hollywood loves being
like relatable and like we're probably
the curtain back in Christy Teegan is
gonna show you but you know what what
she's showing you was fine so yes she's
really showing you know some nasty
things you know who should never be
allowed back at the Vanity Fair Oscar
party is Jessica Alba okay oh hey Chad
hey well I don't think he was allowed in
because his dad weren't even allowed
back Jessica Alba abusing tik-tok and
her friendship she made three tic TOCs
at the Vanity Fair Oscar party and the
bigger crime is that she used the same
song for all three tic TOCs and the same
dance the first one was with Sofia
Vergara the second two were with Leslie
Mann and some other woman like just out
of control her tic tacs are so cringy in
general and she's the type of tic toc ER
who like makes all people above the age
of
20 to look bad yeah I actually like some
of her tic TOCs especially when she does
them with her daughter who weirdly looks
like me does she oh my god have you not
seen no it's everyone tags me in her
videos like she has red hair she
seriously looks like she could be my
daughter
but I look nothing like Jessica Alba or
Warren oh yes she does look like you
yeah so I did I think it's cute when
she's on tik-tok for her daughter and
they're doing it together but when you
go to like this party and you're
teaching everyone tape talk dance it's
like so that your videos will go viral
it's like you're Jessica Alba like you
have a billion dollar company it's okay
relax also like you're at the best party
in the world have fun it's not making
content yeah like people are wrap it as
they really go go then like these other
people aren't doing these dances on
tik-tok so she's also teaching them
dances and you could see in the video
she's mouthing right left up like that's
not fun no that's not fun at all like
I'm fun unless like you're a 17-year old
tape talker I feel like I like that
stupid party like if I ever wanna be
invited to like I wouldn't even have fun
just like you can't drink you really
just want to like be in the moment like
I said hide everyone like just terrible
yeah I feel like it's also the kind of
party where people might get all dressed
up go get their photo taken and go home
yeah but what Chrissy Teigen is saying
is like if you do make it all the way
and it's actually so fun yeah which is
nice I feel like maybe those parties
aren't always fun but hearing from
Chrissy Teigen that like this particular
one is actually a blast makes me want to
go and I feel like it should be a great
place for celebrities to meet each other
and like start relationships yes you can
meet sorry drive it across Jojo
totally I think that's how Jessica
Simpson and John Mayer met at the Clive
Davis Grammys part did they I feel like
they would have run into each other like
we're anyways on the same label so he
used to like go to her album release
parties and was weird but she was still
with Nick that was weird for the first
time they connected post Nick was at the
Clive Davis Grammys Borgata the Clive
Davis Grammys parties also like
apparently one of those I don't know
like where to go to say all my thoughts
about Jessica Simpson's [ __ ] tell of
the most interesting I'm sorry you
literally have a podcast about books but
like I have to dedicate a segment to it
I'll bring my Kindle um I highlighted
some of the many things that she said
some of the most interesting factoids
like Tony Romo keeping $350,000 on cash
checks as bookmarks next to his toilet
why because he just like didn't think
about money and like raised in a frat
house and all his friends would come
over and she be like she had to break up
by the way he seems like a really nice
guy but she realized she had to break up
with him when
playing Madden with his friends yeah and
he was playing himself in the video yeah
that's like a weird thing I mean I like
shift Tony Romo and right I shipped Tony
Romo and Jessica Simpson so much back in
the day everyone she wrote about in her
book I shipped til the end until of
course Eric right like the one yeah but
she just loved so hard and then you love
so hard with her also like the you
remember the jeans right of course mom
Jean of course so Rascal Flatts are some
of the unsung heroes of this book as
well because she was born with them she
was opening for them Basava you're
ruining it I really do want to get it
yeah okay
but like a bench Allah okay so like if
you could read it really soon we could
do a speed read version of the redheads
menu yes I saw a whole version of I mean
I saw a whole thread about those mom
jeans on Twitter recently and it's just
so interesting how like times have
really changed because those mom jeans
nobody would have said anything about
them today
um yes because we don't talk that way
about people but it was just it was so
crazy I remember those jeans like they
were everywhere and what she says in the
book is like what she didn't say when
she could have gone on like late night
and he hasn't been like those jeans are
a size 25 I'm not that much different
but she didn't want to make it seem like
she was already such a body she is like
the body positivity I kind of our
generation because she didn't want
people to feel like oh it's okay because
they're 25 right right that makes it
better yeah no totally how much she's
everything and she like wouldn't let it
get her down and she was so worried that
Tony Romo was like gonna see the
pictures and they break up with her and
she said he was so nice and so
supportive and he just loved her and he
was so supportive of her music he said
she bought him a boat and needs to go
out on the boat with his friends and he
would make everyone listen to her songs
and be like can you believe she hit that
note say thank you also we said last
week about you know her audiobook has
six songs on there coming out okay but
by the way I bought the audiobook you
did I read the book on Kindle just
because I wanted the songs I think I've
spent like $40 on this book I would give
her I just want to support her in every
which way the songs are so good what I
love about Jessica Simpson's music is
there's no like veiled
sentiments it's alright very
straightforward she's telling you how
she feels you don't have to decipher the
lyrics right and one song party of one
is just that's what you put on a serum
that I heard about everything more than
my body more than my wealth I don't
think I'll ever be more than my wealth
but okay and then our other follow-up to
the story is Khloe Kardashian
tweeting very strangely oh why did Kylie
Jenner and I allow Kourtney Kardashian
to ruin our night last night that's so
crazy but maybe I'm thinking like
because there's no follow up or anything
maybe there was like a weird story going
around about Kourtney ruining their
night so then she tweeted that as a joke
no I really hadn't seen anything about
it and I feel like it's real and
redeeming tonight says that it seems the
reality stars just poking fun at
Kourtney after the group appeared to be
having a great time on social media on
Sun what the hell does Entertainment
Tonight though I don't know I feel like
it's real this is so something that
would've happened
I've even tweet about it there they're
like Ryder died she wouldn't bring a
family fight lay out like that but
that's what they do on Twitter like when
they live tweet the episodes because the
episodes like the show is Britt is
everything so they're gonna bear it
already I'm not filming this
they're not gonna bear it all for
Twitter for no reason oh man I'm dying
to know I hope they're filming at yeah
they're always filming yeah they're
always filming they'll all look sick
Kylie looking like Jessica Rabbit she'll
[ __ ] amazing
[Music]
Kim and Kanye looked amazing I love I
love one it's a family night out and I
feel like they very rarely have it and
if they probably they have fun like they
don't care they're there they're with it
with each other and they're there to
have fun that's what people had said
about the Met Gala like once the
Kardashians started going that it really
became like a Kardashian thing but
what's funny is back in the day they
were known for like not drinking and
like very low-key but now most of them
drink I don't think Kim's on drew and
sometimes she does now Wow left here
drunk with Kim I really hope that Khloe
is invited to the Met Gala but you know
I was just thinking that is a hill I'm
just gonna reside on until May she
deserves it I think she would be him
Kylie kendall and kris always go and so
he is in she like is in the fashion
industry that's true
and but I don't know what relationship
she has with designer nice to have one
he needs to like you know the rough
designer she needs to be there right
because it's respect it's gone on too
long
kendall has modeled for many brands they
all love her Kylie and Kim both have
huge relationships with certain brands
who make outfits for them for all
different things so then being invited
you have to be invited by a designer so
then being invited by designers makes
sense Kris is always there with Tommy
Hilfiger
because their friends in Tommy Hilfiger
should be like someone needs her in
Chloe's someone needs to bring Chloe it
shouldn't be that hard to bring Tristan
interest I don't care how she gets there
she needs to be there I wonder if she'll
be there this year like it's it's
actually crazy how her and Courtney have
never been but like Courtney you know
pretends like not to give a [ __ ] about
that stuff great so you shouldn't be
there but if Chloe goes and they all go
except for Courtney I feel like if Chloe
ever goes she'll have to go with
Courtney because they can't all go
without Courtney I feel like it's every
man for himself when it comes to the
neck out yes it is such a huge feel to
be invited you don't turn it down
because you know you got your sister in
the back like you go when you're in
Kim's first year was as Kanye's plus-one
and i Kendall was probably shortly after
that yeah be sure you say going as a
model right Kylie and now 80s Chloe's
time like just like it was Kansas City
Chiefs time it's Chloe's time and it
Courtney it's it's just not your time
and if anyone has like designer
connections and they have an open spot
at their table like please invite Khloe
Kardashian that's the content I want to
see yeah and now that I think about it
like you know who needs a table and who
will really take care is this new brand
Ralph M Russo oh yeah they make fabulous
gowns Kylie just wore one Olivia Coco's
worn one and they're stunning and they
need a table and they will bring Chloe
100% cuz they're a brand who gets it
totally and I want to say I want a
custom dress like they're sickening and
they know how to dress a woman's body
I completely agree that's a really great
khali when you can already have a table
but if not I feel like they don't I
think they're kind of new we're like
good America needs a table but that's
not a thing I thing if you want to pay
for it do you want to recap the batch
are you ready to okay well our bachelor
recap which we're gonna begin shortly is
brought to you by zip recruiter
decodable co-founder gretchen Heavener
experienced how challenging hiring can
be after unsuccessfully searching for a
new game artist to grow with her
education
tech company but then she switched to
zip recruiter and saw an immediate
difference and you too can-can you can -
oh by signing up for a freeze if
recruiter at zip recruiter comm slash
toasts
super cruder doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them for
you and by using zip recruiters
screening questions to filter candidates
Gretchen found it easier to focus on the
best ones then finding the right one in
fact after posting her job on zip
recruiter Gretchen said she was honestly
surprised she found qualified candidates
so quickly and hired a new game artist
in less than two weeks with results like
that it's no wonder four out of five
employers who post on zip recruit or get
a quality candidate within the first day
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
CY zip recruiter is effective for
businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free at our link zip
recruiter dot-com / toast
that's zip recruiter dot-com / teo AST
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
sign-on hire well ok i'll let you know
cuz toasters are telling me david dobrik
is in new york and so you need to
message aaron it's like aaron i don't
know
that's one of the girls in the blog
squad i just ordered my merchants
morning she toaster i haven't found that
any of them are toasters and it's really
struggle city for me damn okay well what
is he doing in New York
I really have to ask and we have a
meeting with them today perfect okay
we're working on it okay
that's um have you actually just like my
heart stopped you were like stop David
Oh Brooks in the belly okay no that's
her we went from six to four which I
feel like they're really rushing towards
the end in which always six days it yeah
now we're on track but wait last week
when we went from like 13 to 6 in one
week was crazy first one on one was with
Madison he told her he was falling in
love with her and they had like a weird
date where they didn't really do
anything her hair was so frizzy she has
to get it under control and she ended up
talking openly about her faith which is
something she's obviously been wanting
to talk to him about and I really
realized they had a real conversation it
was like things that people who are
actually considering getting married
talked about like it's obvious to me she
refers to the Lord like it's such a big
part of her life she like had such nice
things to say about her data actually
thought like what she was saying was
really lovely how he's able to love her
family so much because he has such like
a strong faith in the Lord and he
responded and I don't think he has a
strong faith but he like didn't want to
lose Maddie so he was like I'll work on
it yeah which I thought was great yeah
but I think ultimately like they're not
a match because it's you don't just like
become faithful you you can if that's
something that's like important to you
but you don't become faithful because
someone wants you to become it's
something that you feel am I like crazy
to think that like Kelsey should win no
here's the thing at this point at this
stage in the game if he is serious about
marriage and not just like being in like
an Instagram relationship with a younger
person he should choose Kelsey if he
really is saying if what if he's mean
what he says about being serious about
this prostitute mean there's two
relationships two types of relationships
happening now we have two girls Madison
and Kelsey who they actually have
profound connections and I think like I
can actually see him showing physical
emotion that he likes them and then
Victoria and how to Anne who are just
too young too immature they just want to
revolve around the world she's a model
they're both models like they're just
not even remotely there for the right
reason and they don't like him
right and the Victoria really doesn't
have hardly a connection with him yeah
it comes down to we have campers and we
have counselors and if he picks a camper
like I will know that this whole thing
was a joke like everything he said he
didn't mean he's not serious about and
this is what Kelly was saying and we
need to talk about Kelly for an
executive in justice Kelly was saying
about how her and Hannah and are
completely different types of girls and
she wasn't even saying like I'm old and
successful and she's she was just saying
like look we're in tutu and even though
they're only like five years apart
they're in such - Kelly happens to be a
very old 27 year old and Hannah Ann
happens to be a very young 23 year old
100% and she's just saying they're
different not ones not better than the
other even some people could probably
argue that oh like Kelly's old and
boring and Helens young and fun like
it's not a better or worse thing it's
just they're different but he's been
saying all this time he wants this
serious serious thing and Carrie Kelly
is that is Reyes girl I just can't
believe he's been saying he wants a
serious serious thing and we somehow
ended up with top four that's made up of
half not serious things and he sent home
two serious things last night I guess
shocked that he sent home Kelly I
thought that the Edit that they the
botched edit that they gave Kelly
towards the end to make us try and
understand why he would you know it was
it was intentional it was all pieced
together those I was trying to finish oh
my god I heard you can heat like who are
they
honey yes exactly putting words together
and it's like at this point we're
smarter than that or I hope that we are
I don't think anything anyone was
falling for such a weird edit because
the whole season Kelly just got a normal
edit no spin on it and then it's like
when they decided to send hit her home
in an attempt to make Peter look good
they made Kelly look bad but no one's
believing it and I'm really glad about
that because it was so choppy copy and
paste like her saying who are they
they're our children she just probably
said those three different words in a
million different conversations and they
pieced it together they tried so hard to
make her look like above it all like a
villain so that
when he sent her home we're not supposed
to think oh like Peters just trying to
[ __ ] around with young girls we're
supposed things like so she was mean
we're glad she went her that she needed
we are not dumb and I refuse this is
like what they when they were trying to
they edited Vanessa Grimaldi to look so
good because she ended up winning that
they made everything else look so weird
but it was just an attempt to make Nick
and Vanessa look good to me clearly make
like he so that's what they did they
took Kelly down in an attempt to keep
Peter hoisted on some pedestal
we're not believing in and now he has
what he wants he has four girls who
aren't gonna question his decisions who
are just gonna be like you know just
excited to get to the end and not want
to get married to him because they just
want to be mega influencers totally cept
for Kelsey I love Kelsey oh oh here's
the thing I Maddy him I'm on the fence
about because she's not just you know
your handler I don't think she's camper
such a camper but she is very young and
after their conversation about faith
when it's clear that like he's not
faithful enough for her he's just not
and next week she gives him an ultimatum
it looks like from the previews that he
can't have sex with any of the other
women if he's gonna be with her
yeah and it's weird because that's kind
of what Luke P said to Hannah but
obviously the way that they say it is
very different and also like he was
being insulting yeah and she's just
saying like this is important to her but
also the previews are always
misconstrued so maybe that's not what
happens it does appear that that's what
happened it'll be really interesting and
it does appear that he does have sex
with someone yeah it looks like he's
having sex with Hannah Hannah in the
bathroom but I could completely
understand Maddie if she was like okay
then you're not the man worse of course
right I mean here's the thing I think
that I don't consider Maddie to be on
the same level as Hannah and Victoria
she's very southern she's very
traditional I feel like even though she
might only be 23 like she really is like
people and people who are very faithful
and don't have sex to marriage get
married very young so I do think she's
actually ready for that and I do think
her either her and Kelsey could win and
I would be totally okay with that
because I think there's a real thing
there like even if you just compare the
dates like he sat down with Maddie and
had a very real conversation about
religion and faith he sat down with
Kelsey she really opened up about actual
[ __ ] she went through like real
substance and let me go back to Hanna
and in Victoria fuller who are just
crying and I got what he crying about
like Kelsey was crying about real things
about her family they're crying about
just nonsense literally like I can't
don't want to say bye this is so hard
what's hard once more this is hard
life is hard you guys if you can't get
through this you will not get their
marriage marriages tough my friends just
see that if you compare the types of
conversations he has with Madison and
Kelsey versus the ones he has with
Victoria and Hanna pull all the girls
crying all the conversations but one
girls are crying Hannah and Victoria are
crying about hypothetical nothings and
Madison and Kelsey are crying about real
life and Kelsey like she cries every
time she sees Peter and I know that's
supposed to make us think that what
she's crazy but like I think it's so
sweet and she really is an emotional
person and she totally owns that but she
loves him so much and who wouldn't want
to be with someone like I wish Ben would
cry every time he saw me and I think the
the bachelor process everything the
emotions are so high even girls who
probably would never look at Peter twice
are like looking at him twice
right um so - already like him and then
have that environment just and there in
these most romantic locations like that
date when they were laying I'm like the
top of the hilltop was so beautiful and
like that's not really my scene no me
neither I couldn't making her run up the
hill I wanted to kill her it was just
lovely like there's losing the clouds
and I think that I really like it's just
weird they've edited edited it so
strangely because we're supposed to
think Kelsey's crazy but also has a real
lit connection with Peter which they've
never done before either you're crazy
villain or you're really there for Peter
so I felt conflicted and feeling like
she should win ya know in Michaela like
that never went in in every episode
there's a new villain I guess they don't
want to just like be hell-bent on
destroying one person's life every
season I guess it's responsible but it
makes it confusing confuses or the
viewer because I'm like but wait this is
a girl who's crying over champagne right
right right I know and even though I
thought that was funny like it's that
person actually you can beat cry over
champagne and be ready for marriage I
don't know if someone we don't know why
that champagne was so special other than
the fact that it was a bottle of Dom
like maybe someone gave it to her for a
big occasion right no I would like some
clarification on why she was crying
about this she because to me the way
they edited her is so inconsistent
like is she the crazy drunk girl who
pops pills you know or is she just like
a really love her I really love her I
think she's so cute she's miss Iowa like
she has like a she loves Iowa she loves
the show exciting picked up the Rosie
what like she's so cute I think she's a
stated for the show to come to Iowa for
her to like show Iowa you know in
another life she should have ended up
with crystals totally but that his life
had other plans for her I think also in
another life I do for some reason I
don't think she ends up with Peter he's
not smart enough to choose her that's
what I'm saying and I do think she could
be the Bachelorette they should be
amazing Nick vile or Kelly and he boy
are really shipping Kelly and Nick fail
because he lives Suites every episode
and he has been so vocal about her how
she's just like an intellect she's so
mature and everyone's like responding
like can you date her cuz he's also like
so woke he want he like it's not
threatened by like an independent woman
who's an attorney and I actually think
that they would be perfect together and
she lives in LA Ryan I think she's in
Florida
oh but didn't she meet Peter in LA she
was at a wedding oh so but I'm pretty
sure she lives in Florida or that's
where she's from
at least she's so cute and perfect
she's so justice for her and they just
tried to like kick her out and make her
look bad but I refused I do think she
should be the Bachelorette yeah but
don't you think she would home a little
early um things happened it's not so you
know cut and dry anymore that it's like
the third person who goes home and nice
girl unless it's gonna be Kelsey as the
bachelor but it's either her or someone
who really is ready for marriage and the
Bachelorette is always different from
the bachelor because the women choose
aside from Hannah brown like the best
guy for them and they're still together
and you know right Rachel for the most
part it was in between I was gonna say
Kappa Becca yes living like a low-key
life yeah for the most part the women
who get chosen as the bachelor like know
how lucky they are to be the
Bachelorette and they know that it's an
experience that they'll never get again
and very few people get in their lives
and they really use it as an opportunity
to find their husbands the boys just
like [ __ ] around like crystals they
broke up two weeks later like the boys
don't take it as seriously on The
Bachelor but the women are much smarter
and they really use it as an opportunity
to find love so they can't have like a
Hannah Ann because she's again is not in
that type of position it has to be a
calcio or Kelly and I was having such a
hard time like recapping talking a bed
about it Kelsey Kelly Kelly I kept
calling them each other because it's not
confusing but or I guess Madison could
put a 23 year old bachelorette it's just
in the Virgin thing we just did it yeah
oh that's true I can't have another
season of like puns about virginity
very very true but then I get torn
because I'm not sure if The Bachelor
wants to be like the
powers that be they want it to be about
like love and it could be real and you
can find marriage and they want us to
take it so seriously but then on the
other hand this season they have
challenges like the revolve D right and
the Cosmo date that it's really
America's Next Top influence right no
you're so right if they want to lean
into the fact that these people become
influencers and it's this whole
ecosystem or you're gonna find your wife
in six weeks Jackie you're so right and
I think they're confused and and I'm
feeling the confusion as a viewer and
I'm confused and I'm getting migraines
yeah thank you all and although it was a
good episode justice for Natasha she
never stood a chance he never gave her
the time of day because she's a smart
independent woman and I think that I
loved her me too I thought she'll be
great on Paradise I think that the
conversation that they had he kept
trying to get her to like open up and
send herself home so he didn't have to
do it but she's like nothing I thought
it was epic honestly like it wasn't
there that all that many girls that had
two one-on-ones wouldn't even got one
yet because to me that's just not
playing fair
it's how was she ever expected and then
he says we just haven't had that
connection but it's like you chose to
not take differences I'm actually
totally it's so [ __ ] yeah agreed when
that date card came in it was for
Madison again I was like you [ __ ]
kidding me and Victoria last week had
our second one-on-one like come on you
know what it is it's one plus one equals
sock that's definitely what it is
justice for her justice for the fact
that she only has 30,000 Instagram
followers like all the toasters need to
follow her it's not fair she got robbed
Julie is 31,000 Instagram followers and
Madison is that almost 700,000 so it's
interesting Madison's leading the pack
but she had the most to begin with oh
she did and Kelsey's also very low down
which makes me think that she doesn't
win she's like 130 that's so where many
people aren't just are just aren't
following people like they used to IPL
see also is posting like very
sporadically and she doesn't have a flow
on point like it's a terrible Instagram
Oh interest she's gotta go yeah Madison
has slowed I was looking at her and she
had flow before we even started with
Hanna and she's just bored revolved
girls her uh Kelly is the only one that
I followed and I think she's in like the
hunter case which isn't a lot for a fan
favorite and for someone who made it so
far yeah we're at hometowns next week
which it looks like he something happens
with Victoria yeah she's but it's
something always happens with Victoria
to be nothing oh and she's shy did you
know that so shy so show you to your
Instagram or titties are everywhere like
I can't she's not try like she was
afraid me
no cover shoot but like a literally her
Instagram is like porn oh really
I checked she also doesn't have that
many followers and then last week I
looked at Sydney cuz I thought she was
just like Instagram gold doesn't have
that many followers I think maybe we're
like phasing out of the time when
literally Raven who came in second maid
got a million followers yeah
but then also I think more people follow
during Paradise you get a sense of
people's styles yes maladies and clothes
yeah it's just a longer it's a slower
burn yeah this season really happened
very fast I find it so much more
enjoyable again to watch when there's a
an attainable amount of girls like now I
know everyone's names I get it like the
last few episodes have been very
overwhelming because all the girls look
the same and I can't remember anyone's
name but now we're like in it yeah and
now I have I have horses in this race so
we have hometowns then we could think I
mean we talked about this yesterday
aside from something crazy happening
like I kind of coming back who do you
think he plans on getting down on one
knee to Madison even though like it
should be Kelsey but to me you're right
like he's not smart enough to see
actually but he really has been very
good to Kelsey like all the girls have
mean he really defended her he's
protected her so kept her before I even
knew that he was needed to keep her
right and so we've seen I birthed you
how hard it was for me to not cry to you
we've seen her like evolved into this
butterfly but she was like a little bit
of a mess in the beginning and he
protected her so maybe he does see what
we see but to me he's just making such
poor decisions that the biggest decision
of the season he's not going to make the
right one yeah I would say it's gonna be
Madison but it looks like next week how
how are they gonna I mean it's exactly
the style the fact that like it just
thought sleeps or something but it of
course can't be a Hannah or Victoria
like there's really no connection there
like it's the the difference between all
four of these girls is huge like to me
it's Kelsey Madison Victoria had at
least I would say Victoria's in a
different level in Hanna am because I
think there's something about her that
Peters obsessed with I think they have
like a good just sexual chemistry I
think cuz she's so pretty yeah she's
getting prettier every episode she's
literally stunning she's doing her
makeup and her like even better every
episode she really always has the right
makeup look for the occasion like when
they're doing girl talks in the hotel
she almost looks like she's not wearing
makeup but I was wearing no she's
literally like one of the most beautiful
girls and I actually don't even like her
but she's one of those beautiful girls
I've ever seen on the show like
naturally beautiful yeah I totally agree
and then Hannah and it's like I don't
even see half a connection I don't see
any I see a friend she wrote that note
that liferaft have a note she is so
smart she says what she has seen a
million episodes my walls were up so I
wrote this letter to take them down
there's nothing like honestly letters
are so beautiful and personal like if
someone wrote me a letter I would keep
them around yeah Kelly had written a
letter she would still be there but
Kelly didn't feel like she had to play
this game because they had a real
connection and she's a mature woman and
you think that a real connection is
enough to get you at least two hometowns
but no someone else wrote a letter so
you gotta go yeah
also Victoria s like turning that
conversation where she was like telling
him he was in a bad mood she wants to go
home but then she turned it around and
was like I guess I'm pushing him away
because I'm scared of losing you and I
just said I'd rather I'd rather lose you
I'm not even try at all I never have you
I was like oh [ __ ] Shakespeare no she by
the way she's dying to go home she's had
a no but then she wanted to stay because
she pulled that line out of her ass yet
to me she thought she was going home he
walked her to the car yeah I thought she
was going home oh I knew that he was
that she he wouldn't have brought the
rose to torture her oh right that was
weird that he did bring the rose and
it's like I saw meme last week that was
like Victoria F trying to figure out if
she's been on The Bachelor long enough
to become famous yet like she doesn't
know but she doesn't have an Instagram
followers so honestly she needs more
week I think her her plan is to be so
start and stopped that she'll get to the
end but he would never choose her
because it's to answer it's yeah it's
not as easy being there but she doesn't
want him to be in love with her right
that was like that terrible conversation
we had to sit there with Cassie and
Colton the one he eventually jumped the
fence still together they'd only have I
saw them driving um
listening to Luke Holmes on Instagram
the other day being so cute they're
still just dating right am i really
normal and to me it's like we can talk a
lot of [ __ ] on the show but the proof is
in the pudding
yeah and they're putting that's like a
that's a delicious-looking pudding yeah
it's chocolate and they have a nice life
in LA and they're being a very normal
couple I sure I forgot that they were so
nice and we really have no choice but to
buy a respective a little rowboat and
start to ship a little you'll start out
with a little row but maybe we've got a
motorboat yeah like a speedboat yeah
they are just dating so honestly like
they really don't have a lot to lose and
it probably makes it a lot easier and
more relaxed to just like get to know
each other but they're choosing to be
together a lot of people wait until they
can
we break up but they're there trying and
they're living a normal life and and I I
respect it so anyone can like make
decisions we don't agree with on this
show but it's all about what you do
after we write when the cameras go down
that's true okay well it was a good
episode we got next week hometowns and
then women tell all after that so it'll
be interesting love Kelsey can't ship
her enough with Peter hopefully he makes
the right decision
and that's what we got for you is that
anything else anything else we need to
talk about listen to the new episode of
the redheads
yeah episode of date night with Raven
and Adam came out yesterday new episode
of the snatchler is out today and then
tomorrow there's an episode of day night
with Raven and Adam so we are just
giving you content all week long so make
sure you're following at toast news
network I have to listen to the
snatchler because I want to know what
she thinks because we always think so
differently I think that they ultimately
ship Madison and Peter they love Madison
I like her too I just don't think she's
their age I yeah she's just met for me
but there's nothing wrong with her
no there's nothing wrong with her she
seems really nice this episodes ending
head over to the redheads listen to the
first episode whether you've read the
book or not but if you're in the middle
of the book wait to listen to the
episode thank you so much for listening
to the morning toast the Millennial
morning show where we can I just say one
more oh yeah if you feel like you were
left behind you didn't read the first
book but there wasn't that much time the
next book that we're reading is red
white and royal blue so you can start it
now so you can listen to the next
episode and we caught up yeah these so
much for listening to the morning show
so millennial morning show where we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe give this video a thumbs up
and maybe leave a comment I'm we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so that's Spotify iTunes
stitcher public with you I already owe
cashbox all the places so wherever you
choose to listen to podcasts find us the
morning toast hi how are you leave a
review 5 stars comment about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are
whatever it's up to you just some
guidance
have a great one more thing because I
saw in the comments if you're interested
in learning more about Kathleen Colton's
relationship listen to a mood with
Lauren Elizabeth her episode with Cassie
and Michelle because it's it's fabulous
thank you so much have a great day